hahaha
you're asking the room yeah our men are
women the prize all right cool give me a
second oh women depressed are you so
women the prize women are depressed okay
wait tell me why because they're the
ones that we're going for well me
personally I'm game for the woman and I
want to go for the women that I believe
is the right woman and someone who else
many people would want okay go ahead no
I made it the price
um we we run Society we keep Society
going I'm not saying women
of the prize we're another prize okay
what do you think men or woman who's
surprised
the
the prize for like I okay wait let me
just
so are men or women the prize in what
sense like in the world or in in the
dating game in The Dating Game
well women okay women are the prize what
do you think nasty 50 50. you think like
half a woman half a man okay fair enough
go ahead men men are the prize what do
you think Auntie
okay man there's more women anyway so I
can remember the prices so many of them
running out running out there it's gonna
be men so second question are do women
date up or down
day day up okay
um when they can help you okay do women
date up or down uh day up yeah I
answered for me personally up up okay
they date down they sleep up
so if women if women date up wouldn't
that make men the prize
it's a good point really
I get the point but I don't I still
don't see men as the price
why not
said let me get this right you've
acknowledged the point
I understand where I understand the
point allow me to finish so you've
acknowledged the point right but you
don't agree can you explain why no I you
asked me who are the prize and relate I
still I'm still I'm an annoying about
the question about the on the question
anyway like who's the pride sort of
because then it's like the whole value
thing and all that sort of stuff so
that's why I just said women just to
give an answer that women are the prize
because of
what they bring to a relationship or
whatever it is right I just said it just
whatever but then what was it you said
again that why do women date up I said I
said do women date up or down and so if
majority of the women here said date up
yeah why would and then a man would be
the prize yes but then dating up you're
not dating down so so if they're dating
up then the men are dating down
because oh no but yeah but if women are
dating up
and men are dating down you're saying
that women are not the prize that a man
is the price yeah so then men would just
date men because men are the prized why
are men dating down if a man is
surprised when all men just date all
men's
this is like this okay okay okay okay
we're talking we're talking about
straight people okay yeah why would men
date each other when they're straight I
like this isn't you just said men are
the uh would make men the price yeah
because man could date up but they don't
they date down yeah so then men would be
the prize that means they don't have a
choice
there's some women that would be up
there are some women that would be down
there are women that would be up like
Oprah is up right so then a man has to
be above her to date down to her the
Oprah's not up no I'm just general like
I'm just saying like value money
no no that's not up though so what's up
then
[Laughter]
that means he's dating up yes it depends
on her personality as well okay I
personally
Tesco personality she's 20 she's young
she's her body count is zero whatever
then the man is dating up yeah do you
know her there's some guys that might
want to get her
so she would be considered high in them
so she's high value yeah yeah in the
Dayton Market yeah so then wait here
here's my thing yeah you're now starting
to understand how men think we we're
totally okay
so if that is a woman that is high value
yeah and then why would that woman want
to date you wouldn't she want to date
someone high value someone up yeah yeah
that's why that's why one in three men
are virgins are having had sex in the
past year because nobody wants them so
so you're saying men are dating down
yeah so by dating down you're saying
he's dating someone over 25 30 whose
number account is up whose eggs are
cracked and yeah I mean guys look guys
he's dating guys will put up with more
than men do so they will put up with
more and date I'm sorry yeah the the guy
will put up with more and date down yeah
because he doesn't have a choice but
he'll still cheat on that woman he still
has a right to not be monogamous sir
because her value is low it depends but
you don't have a choice because no the
high value woman doesn't want you so
you're dating down right but a lot of
high value women die alone because
that's what I'm talking about I mean
dialogue so guys
wait wait wait what are we defining as a
high value sorry I'll explain a lot of
things
went a lot of eight to tens that are
very pretty dialogue because they can't
leave the streets because they're so
used to the attention like that like
what sorry go ahead then you still use
the attention
um this is like honestly I've just heard
this from guys this is like strictly
this is just the experience that I've
had like talking to guys the last like
two years yeah and they just say a lot
of girls that are like very pretty and
they're given like like that's the most
valuable thing you can be given is
Extreme Beauty like you come out you can
get a modeling contract and girls waste
it and they waste their best years that
doesn't make you high value you're right
sorry sorry technically if we're gonna
go high value woman the man I misused
the term like a high value woman
technically has to be chosen by a high
value manager I just met like like very
attractive women that are like the most
sought after they wouldn't be you're
right I use the roster in the streets
yes and I'm saying like a lot of like
the most beautiful women die alone
because they're they're so used to being
like an eight to ten that's their whole
personality they can't they break up
have been bullied like like if you tell
a girl she's not special they freak out
that would make you low value
if you're if you're beautiful but you
don't have any other qualities you're
still in the streets you're still a
whole you're low value yeah the
equivalent would be a [ __ ] I don't
know a cryptocurrency but well you're
not you're not low value if you're okay
if you're if you're beautiful you like
oh like someone that's 300 pounds isn't
going to get in the same like she could
have a nobody count you're gonna get the
initial attention yeah but if you have
nothing else in your home yeah like your
background correct correct but that's
that's why I say like girls that are
eight to tens often die alone that's
that's what I was saying because because
they're so used to that attention that
they it's like a drug they can't they
can't they can't so wait wait this is
just this is just what I've heard from
men okay so like it depends on nobody
honestly it depends on your culture your
background like sorry the last yeah if
you look at we can go to like Instagram
chicks yeah
the majority of them are single your
Bernice order them and they may get
gifts they may get dated but are they
kept how many of them do you see that
are kept this is the point that you're
referring to looks only but that's what
that's what we're saying eight to tens
yeah but that's that's low value so wow
no no no so what she's saying is when
you start with looks like we as much as
people want to pretend that you know
this personality stuff matters the
initial attraction is looks yeah so when
you are attractive and you have pretty
privilege yeah you're gonna get
attention so what she's saying is when
you get that sort of attention it's like
a drug you go out and you know that
you're gonna have The Pick of men coming
to attract and move to and talk to you
and sell you drinks exactly right but
you're still not being kept at the end
of the day no one is going to turn that
attraction and those dreams into
marriage in to a ring